are movie stars known for being faithful
You could argue you could say well Pearl
but Pearl but Pearl but Pearl what about
businessmen and you know what I actually
agree there's a sector of businessmen
that don't cheat but they tend to be the
nerdier guys that aren't the best
looking that get money and then they get
a wife but they're still not typically
the guys that women throw themselves at
but any man that has women throwing
themselves at him left and right over a
long period of time tend to cheat I'll
give you an example you could be married
for 10 years let's say there's women
trying to sleep with you for 40 years
you don't think that at some point in
the next 40 years you might slip up most
men probably will at some point now is
that saying I like it is that me
encouraging it no that is my opinion on
cheating no I don't want to be chea